We're on problem 16.
They draw the axes.
x-axis, that's the y-axis.
I wish there was the parabola
drawing tool
here, but there isn't.
There's the parabola, it looks
something like this.
They tell us that this
is the point 1.
Fair enough.
This is, of course, the y-axis,
this is the x-axis.
The figure above show that the
graph of a quadratic function
h who's maximum value
is h of 2.
So this is its maximum
value right here.
When x is equal to 2, its
maximum is h of 2.
If h of a is equal to 0--
so where does this
function equal 0?
It equals 0 two places.
Here and here, right?
Its y value is 0 in
those two places.
So this could be a or that could
be a, we don't know.
Which of the following
could be a?
So we're saying this could
be a or this could
be a, we don't know.
And we know that this is 2,
so a is either going to be
greater than 2 or less than 0.
Or actually, we can actually
figure out what a is, right?
Because if this is the maximum
point, it's going to be
symmetric around the point 2.
So the distance from 2 to a on
this side has to be the same
as the distance from 2 to a on
this one-- Actually that
doesn't help.
So let's look at the choices.
It could be negative 1--
that looks fair because
it's less than 0.
a can't be 0-- 0
is this point.
Let me pick a color.
That's 0.
That's definitely not where you
inter-- they draw it so
that you can't be there.
It can't be 2 because that's
actually where the maximum
point is, so a definitely
isn't 2.
Can a be 3?
And this is where the symmetry
comes into play.
We know that it does not
intersect the x-axis for at
least-- on the left-hand side
you go 1, 2, and then some
distance which we don't really
know, but you're going more
than 2 on this side.
So you're also going
to have to go more
than two on this side.
You're going to have to go 1,
2, and then some distance.
So this is 2, 3, 4.
So you know that a has to be
less than 0, or a has to be
greater than 4.
And if you look at all of the
choices, the only-- negative 1
is less than 0.
None of the other ones
are greater than 4.
And how did I know
greater than 4?
Because it's symmetric.
If this is the maximum point
at 2, and one of the places
where I intersect the x-axis
is more than 2 to the left,
the other place where I
intersect the x-axis has to be
more than 2 to the right.
So it has to be greater
than 4.
This has to be less than 0, this
has to be greater than 4.
And that's the answer.
Negative 1.
Next problem.
And you really didn't have to--
once you felt comfortable
with negative 1 you could have
just said well that's the
answer because it can very
easily have intersected the
x-axis at x equals negative 1.
Problem 17-- and that was the
first choice, which tends to
be convenient.
Let me get a brighter color.
Problem 17.
If k and h are constants and
x squared plus kx plus 7 is
equivalent to, equals, x plus 1
times x plus h, what is the
value of k?
Well at first sight it doesn't
seem like we could solve this,
but maybe we can, let's try.
x squared plus kx plus 7 is
equal to x squared plus x
plus hx plus h.
And so this equals x squared.
What's 1x-- right, x is
the same thing as 1x--
what's 1x plus xh?
Well that's 1 plus hx plus h,
right, I just combined these
two terms, added their
coefficients.
And we say x squared plus kx
plus-- oh, well actually,
maybe we can solve this because
we can just match up
terms. We say this term matches
up to this term.
This term matches
up to that term.
So we know, h is equal to 7.
And if h is equal to 7, what
is this term equal to?
That term is going to be
equal to 7 plus 1 is 8.
And this term, what does
this term match up to?
It matches up to this.
We're just kind of matching
coefficients.
If this is 8 than
k is equal to 8.
And that's choice D.
At first I was like how am
I going to solve this?
That's why you should always
just move forward and see if
you see any patterns.
Next problem.
Problem 18.
y, x, and then they
draw a line here,
something like that.
You go from A to C-- oh, the
line keeps going, and then
there's the point up here,
which is the point
here, this is 4,10.
So this is 10 and this is 4.
This is A, B, C.
In the figure above if the
legs of triangle ABC are
parallel to the axes-- this is
parallel to that, this is
parallel to that, so this is
going to be a right angle.
Which of the following could
be the lengths of
the sides of ABC.
Interesting.
So this is really just a slope
problem because what they want
you do is figure out the ratio
of this side to this side.
So what is the slope
of this line?
Well it rose 10-- change in y
over change in x is equal to
10 minus 0, which is 10 over
4 minus 0, which is 4.
That equals 5 over 2.
So for every one it moved
to the right, it's going
to go 5 over 2 up.
So if this is x, this is
going to be 5 over 2x.
So first we should look for--
the two shorter sides are
going to have this ratio.
1 to 5 over 2.
So if you look at the first
choice, choice A, 2 and 5, if
this is 2, if x is equal to 2,
then what's 2 times 5 or 2?
Well this will be 5, right?
That'll be 5.
So that satisfies that ratio.
And you could even figure out
rise is 5 when run is 2, which
is the slope of 5 over 2.
Now you just have to confirm
that they gave the right
length for this longer side.
So we just us Pythagorean
Theorem.
The length of that side's going
to be the square root of
this squared plus
this squared.
The square root of 4 plus
25, which equals the
square root of 29.
So the sides could be
2, 5 squared to 29.
And that is choice A.
Choice B has 2 and 5, but then
it gives 7, assuming that you
didn't know how to do the
Pythagorean Theorem.
Next problem.
Problem 19.
Let f be defined by f of x
is equal to 2x minus 1.
If 1/2 times f of the square
root of t is equal to 4, what
is the value of t?
So let's just evaluate
this expression.
So it's 1/2 times what?
f of the square root of t-- so
everywhere we see x we stick
in a square root of t.
So 1/2-- that 1/2 is
just this 1/2.
f of the square root of t
is 2 times the square
root of t minus 1.
I just replaced x with
the square root of t.
And we know that
this equals 4.
Let's multiply both sides by 1/2
and you get-- or multiply
both sides by 2-- the 1/2
gets canceled out here.
So you get 2 square root of
t minus 1 is equal to 8.
And you get 2 square root of 5,
adding 1 to both sides is
equal to 9.
Let me continue it here.
Divide both sides by 2 you get
the square root of t is equal
to 9 over 2.
And now we can square
both sides of this.
So you get t is equal to--
what's 9 over 2 squared?
It's 81 over 4, and
that is choice E.
And then let's see
if I have time.
I have 50 seconds.
Let me see if I can squeeze
in video 20 in here.
If k is a positive integer,
which of the following must
represent an even integer
that is twice the
value of an odd integer.
So k is any positive integer.
So I want an even number
that is twice the
value of an odd integer.
So an odd integer-- if this is
any integer, an odd integer
can be represented this--
2 times k plus 1.
This is definitely going
to be odd integer.
You can try it out with
k is 1, 2 or 3.
So if I want double this,
I just multiply it by 2,
I get 4k plus 2.
And that is choice E.
And you could try it out
with some numbers.
You just have to take my word
that that has to be an odd
integer and then
you double it.
I'll see you in the
next section.